una visita para evaluar daños el
presidente de Ucrania volodín mirt
selensky recorrió este jueves varias
localidades de la sureñas región de
gersón para conocer de primera mano la
situación de la población local el
mandatario junto a las autoridades
locales conoció algunos de los búnkers
de guerra centros de operaciones y
asistencia e instalaciones energéticas
también se reunió con los lugareños a
quienes prometió Reparar los daños
causados por los combates creo que
restauraremos todo muy rápido sobre todo
necesitamos electricidad sí lo hemos
oído todo el mundo está trabajando en
ello y las casas de las personas que
quedaron destruidas
sobre el devenir de la guerra
[Música]
me dijeron que el agua potable se
proporciona un par de días a la semana
creo que todos lo resolveremos
la pregunta más importante Cuándo es la
victoria
habrá Victoria habrá Victoria estamos
seguros de ello que sea pronto gerson
fue ocupada por las tropas rusas hasta
finales del pasado año cuando la
contraofensiva del ejército de kiev
forzó La retirada estratégica de las
tropas del kremlin una estrategia que
podría estar cerca de replicarse tras la
asistencia militar proporcionada por
occidente según confirman Fuentes
militares en Ucrania en paralelo en
Bruselas este jueves inició la Cumbre de
líderes europeos para debatir una amplia
gama de cuestiones entre las que están
la ayuda que según parece están
dispuestos a seguir brindando para
frenar La amenaza de